[Musik]
dieses Jahr ist es bereits zweimal
passiert sowohl im Mai als auch Ende
September stand die Regierung der
mächtigen USofA vor nichts Geringerem
als ihrem finanziellen shutdown zwar
konnte ihre Zahlungsunfähigkeit beide
Male knapp und mit Hilfe abenteuerlicher
politischer Winkelzüge abgewendet werden
aber eigentlich wurden sie nicht
wirklich abgewendet sondern nur wieder
aufgeschoben wir haben auf unserem
schwesterkanal visualon ausführlich
darüber berichtet ja und jetzt haltet
euch fest es ist aufgrund der aktuellen
krückenlösung sogar schon absehbar wann
die Amis wieder gegen die Wand fahren
werden nämlich schon Mitte November
2023 dieses Thema scheint ein schier
unlösbarer Dauerbrenner zu sein und
viele nehmen es gerade deswegen nicht
mehr wirklich ernst aber dies könnte
sich als verhängnisvoller Fehler
erweisen denn die Folgen der Ignoranz
könnten katastrophal sein 11 mai 203
sagt dass die Zahlungsunfähigkeit der
USA eine weltweite wirtschaftliche
Rezession auslösen würde wie gesagt
damals konnte die Krise noch abgewendet
werden als Präsident Biden am 27 Mai
eine Einigung mit dem republikanischen
Block im Kongress über die Verlängerung
der kreditaufnahmegrenze der
Bundesregierung
verkündetee Kompromiss war dann schon
der Art Brant und mit heißer Nadel
gestrickt dass der für ihn maßgeblich
verantwortliche republikanische Sprecher
des Kongresses dafür von seinen eigenen
heartliner Parteikollegen anschließend
abgewählt wurde es handelte sich um
einen historisch einmaligen Vorgang ihr
Vorwurf McCarthy hätte mit den
Demokraten paktiert um einen faulen
Kompromiss durchzudrücken t und damit
ist das Chaos perfekt nicht nur
Parlaments und parteipolitisch sondern
vor allem fiskalisch seht euch einfach
mal an in was für für einem Sumpf die
selbsternannte großartigste Nation der
Welt
[Musik]
steckt wie ihr nur unschwer erkennen
könnt bleiben die Vereinigten Staaten
Schuldengrenze hin oder her eines der
Länder mit dem schlechtesten Verhältnis
von BIP zu Schulden in der Welt und
nicht nur das die US-Wirtschaft wird in
den kommenden Jahrzehnten mit noch viel
größeren Risiken konfrontiert sein
Risiken die wenn sie eintreten die ganze
Weltwirtschaft wahrlich aus ihren Fugen
werfen könnten und deshalb meine Lieben
Zuschauer werden wir uns hier auf
visualpolitik ein paar verdammt
dringende Fragen stellen um sie
anschließend natürlich zu beantworten
könnte es passieren dass ankel Sam eines
Tages seine Schulden einfach nicht mehr
bezahlen kann wie oft ist das in der
Vergangenheit schon passiert ist mit der
Anhebung der Schuldenobergrenze alles
wieder in Ordnung und wie solide sind
die finanzpolitischen Kontrollen der
US-Regierung in diesem Video werden wir
all diese Fragen beantworten und zwar
gleich nach der flotten Botschaft
unseres heutigen Sponsors rich Wallet
als jemand der viel Rad fährt und reist
müssen meine persönlichen Gegenstände
kompakt sein und sich meinem aktiven
Lebensstil anpassen und ehrlich gesagt
mit einem dicken Portemonnaie kann man
heutzutage wirklich niemanden wber
eindrucken tja und genau an dieser
Stelle kommt rich ins Spiel es geht
nicht nur um das schlanke saubere und
kompakte Design mit dem rich meiner
Meinung nach übrigens voll in Schwarze
getroffen hat nein es geht auch darum
dass man dabei keine elementaren
Funktionen eines zuverlässigen
Geldbeutels missen muss mehr noch es
bietet darüber hinaus auch noch
zusätzliche innovative Features so sind
mit der RFID blocking Technologie meine
Karten V unerwünschten auslesen und
ausspielen sicher unterm Strich kann ich
einfach nur sagen dass mir rich eine
rund um gutes Gefühl gibt aber gut wer
bin ich schon nun ich bin nicht der
einzige da wären z.B über 80.005 Sterne
Bewertungen die das herausragende Design
und die Funktionalität des rich Wallet
in der Praxis unterstreichen skeptisch
kein Problem rich bietet eine 99 Tage
Testphase an also falls es doch nichts
für dich ist einfach innerhalb von 99
Tagen nach dem Kauf zurücksenden
entweder gegen volle Rückerstattung oder
Umtausch und zwar ohne lästige Fragen
aber rich kann noch mehr als nur
Geldbeutel schaut euch z.B die robusten
key casases und innovativen Rucksäcke an
entworfen für Menschen die ständig
unterwegs sind oder einfach nur auf
ihrem täglichen Weg zur Arbeit oder
Schule Handlichkeit mit Style
Funktionalität und Ästhetik verbinden
wollen persönlich nutze ich sowohl das
Wallet als auch den keycase von Rich und
die störende Unordnung in meinen Taschen
hat sich damit in Luft aufgelöst in den
rich key cases kannst du bis zu sechs
Schlüssel sicher und ohne lästiges l
verwahren und das beste erwirbst du ein
rich volley zusammen mit einem kycase
kommst du in den Genuss von bis zu 30%
Rabatt auf deine Bestellung aber warte
denn das ist noch nicht alles mit dem
Link den du in der Beschreibung dem
Video findest und dem Gutscheincode vpde
bekommst du nochmals weitere 10% Rabatt
auf deinen Einkauf also schlag am besten
schnell zu und erlebe selbst wie rich
dein tägliches Leben bequemer machen
kann so und nun begeben wir uns auf eine
Reise über den großen Teich und
Unternehmen dort eine steile Wanderung
auf den Gigant
Schuldenberg der Armes auf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
geht's wir alle wissen dass die
US-Wirtschaft ein Koloss ist aber von
Zeit zu Zeit wecken Ereignisse wie die
Krise von 2008 oder die ständigen
Drohungen dass der Regierung das Geld
ausgeht viele Zweifel die jüngste Krise
um die Schuldenobergrenze und die
potenzielle Katastrophe die zum Ausfall
einer Volkswirtschaft hätte führen
können deren Währung bei weiten die
wichtigste wertreserve der wel ist ist
ein gutes Beispiel dafür aber wartet
einen Moment denn die Wahrheit ist dass
dieses ganze Problem der Verschuldung
der Haushaltsdefizite und sogar der
Zahlungsausfälle nicht wirklich neu ist
in seiner Abschiedsrede widmete George
Washington persönlich einen Großteil
seiner Worte der Warnung seiner
Nachfolger vor der Gefahr die eine
finanzielle Misswirtschaft mit sich
bringen könnte hört euch z.B diese Worte
vom 19 september
1776 an der öffentliche Kredit ist eine
sehr wichtige Quelle der Stärke und
Sicherheit eine Methode ihn zu bewahren
besteht darin ihn so sparsam wie möglich
einzusetzen nicht nur indem wir Anlässe
für Ausgaben vermeiden sondern indem wir
uns in Friedenszeiten energisch bemühen
die Schulden zu begleichen die
unvermeidliche Kriege verursacht haben
und nicht indem wir die Last die wir
selbst tragen sollten kleinlich auf die
Nachwelt abwälzen George Washington in
seiner Abschiedsrede zur Präsidentschaft
am 19 september
1796 seitdem haben praktisch alle
Präsidenten unabhängig von ihrer
politischen Überzeugung ihre besor über
das enorme Risiko erwachsen
Staatsverschuldung zum Ausdruck
gebracht
ra
[Musik]
all doch trotz all dieser schönen Worte
ist die Wahrheit nun mal dass die
Schulden ungebremst immer weiter steigen
seit 194 wurden die Schuldenobergrenze
etwa 90 Mal angehoben das heißt in etwa
etwas mehr als einmal pro Jahr was aber
eine große Untertreibung ist und daraus
ergibt sich die erste Schlussfolgerung
die Schuldenobergrenze ist in der Praxis
nutzlos sie hat es nicht einmal
geschafft einen Präsidenten nach dem
anderen davon abzuhalten die
unerschöpfliche Kreditkarte der
Bundesregierung zu zücken und die Frage
ist warum um alles in der Welt scheint
jeder US-Präsident süchtig nach Schulden
zu sein wohin steuert dieses Land ist es
Zeit für eine Haushaltsreform nun ja
meine Lieben Zuschauer diese Frage ist
enorm wichtig für die gesamte
Weltwirtschaft und deswegen werden wir
sie uns jetzt genau ansehen
[Musik]
aufgepasst Obergrenze ja Kontrolle
nein wie wir euch bereits auf unserem
schwesterkanal visualconomic erklärt
haben war das was heute als
Schuldenobergrenze bekannt ist ein
Kontrollmechanismus der im Jahr 1917 in
krafttrat bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt musste
jede Kreditaufnahme des
Finanzministeriums ausdrücklich vom
Kongress genehmigt werden um dieses
Verfahren zu vereinfachen und
gleichzeitig die Bundesregierung
weiterhin einer gewissen Kontrolle zu
unterstellen nahmen die US-Politiker
Ihnen dieses Instrument aus der Hand es
wurde eine klar definierte Grenze für
die Schulden die die Bundesregierung
aufnehmen konnte festgesetzt mit anderen
Worten es handelte sich um eine doppelte
Kontrolle einerseits genehmigt der
Kongress die Haushalte andererseits
verhindert er dass der Bund zu viele
Schulden macht es wird also davon
ausgegangen dass diese Grenze bei der
Aufstellung des Haushaltsplans
berücksichtigt werden muss das Problem
dieses Gesetz wurde auf eine Art und
Weise gestrickt dass es sich quasi
selbst eine Falle stellt Jahr für Jahr
gelang es dem Weißenhaus nämlich die
Schuldenbremse immer weiter anzuheben am
Ende war das was eigentlich als hart
Obergrenze gedacht war kaum mehr als ein
schlechter Witz ein Spielball der
Parteipolitik und der
Partikularinteressen und das Ergebnis
ist in dieser Grafik zu
sehen
wie ihr hier sehen könnt stellt die 1940
festgelegte Obergrenze von etwa 49
Milliarden Dollar heute nicht mehr als
einen unbedeutenden Punkt auf eine
Grafik da die den unersettlichen Appetit
der US-Regierung auf immer mehr Schulden
eindrucksvoll visualualisiert bis zum
Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs hatte sich
die Obergrenze verfünffacht und von da
an bis in die 1980er Jahre verdoppelte
sich diese Obergrenze praktisch jedes
[Musik]
Jahrzehnt natürlich gibt es einen
kleinen Haken an der Sache es stimmt
zwar dass die Schulden des Bundes in die
Höhe gestnellt sind aber wenn wir uns
das Verhältnis von Schulden zu BP
ansehen ist das nicht unbedingt der Fall
n ja zumindest war dies über viele
Jahrzehnte nicht der Fall in den 80er
Jahren lag die Verschuldung des Bundes
bei nur 31,7% des BIP das Problem mit
der Schuldenobergrenze ist dass sie wenn
es darauf ankommt keinen anderen Zweck
erfüllt als Spannungen zu erzeugen wenn
die Haushalte sowieso defizitär sind und
die Regierung sich eben verschulden muss
hat sich die Sch Obergrenze als völlig
nutzloser Mechanismus erwiesen außer und
das ist nicht zu übersehen um eine Menge
politischer Unberechenbarkeit und damit
auch wirtschaftlicher Unsicherheit zu
erzeugen von außen und
sicherheitspolitischen Problemen wie
zurzeit in der Ukraine ganz zu schweigen
und aus diesem Grund setzte sich der
Abgeordnete the gephard 1970 für eine
Regel ein die dann nach ihm benannt
wurde die sogenannte gephardreel besagt
dass der Kongress wenn er einen Haushalt
verabschiedet hatte der die
Schuldenobergrenze durchbrach
automatisch die Verlängerung der
schuldenober Grenze
genehmigte als diese Regelung in Kraft
trat lag die Obergrenze bei 830
Milliarden Dollar und als sie
schließlich 1995 wieder aufgehoben wurde
lag die Obergrenze bereits bei 5,5
Billionen Dollar seitdem kommt es jedes
Mal wenn sich die Verschuldung der
Obergrenze nähert zu Kontroversen und
nicht selten zu einem Kampf zwischen dem
Weißen Haus und dem Kongress tja und am
Ende wächst der Schuldenberg immer
weiter und das meine Lieben Zuschauer
hat viel damit zu tun dass beide Seiten
sich immer wieder mit Zugeständnissen
auf Kosten des Steuerzahlers zu
übertrufen versuchen das Jahr 2023 ist
ein gutes Beispiel dafür aber in
Wirklichkeit ist die Schuldenobergrenze
nur eine Seite der Medaille es liegt auf
der Hand dass es keine Schulden gebe
wenn es keine übermäßigen Ausgaben gebe
oder zumindest keine Ausgaben die über
die Einnahmen der Regierung hinausgehen
und dafür sorgt nun mal kein Politiker
in Washington DC weder Republikaner noch
Demokraten aber wie weit reicht das
Problem wirklich haben wir tatsächlich
Grund zur Sorge inwi weit ist das Weiße
Haus gerade zu süchtig nach Schulden nun
genau das sehen wir uns jetzt an
[Musik]
aufgepasst ein außer Kontrolle geratenes
schckbuch meine Lieben Zuschauer ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass die große
Mehrheit von euch Schulden hat eine
Kreditkarte eine Hypothek ein Darlehen
für den Kauf eines Autos und so weiter
und das muss nicht unbedingt etwas
Schlechtes sein es kann sogar etwas
Gutes sein wir könnten uns z.B Geld
leihen um ein Unternehmen zu gründen
oder uns Produktionsgüter zu kaufen die
uns Rentabilität bringen in jeden Fall
stellt es kein Problem da wenn wir es
uns leisten können regelmäßig die Zinsen
zu zahlen und die Schulden mit unserem
Einkommen zu tilen ein Problem entsteht
aber wenn das alles den Bach runtergibt
wenn wir so viele Schulden machen dass
die Zahlen einfach nicht mehr stimmen
denn genau das ist der usbundesregierung
Geschehen eineer Regierung die mit einem
riesigen permanenten haushaltskisier
lebt praktisch mit jedem Jahr werden die
vom weißen Haus ausgestellten schcks
größer und größer und zwar sogar
inflationsbereinigt schaut euch an die
Frage die wir uns alle stellen lautet
also wohin fließt all dieses Geld und ja
ich weiß was viele von euch denken Mark
es ist doch offensichtlich in die
Rüstung und Verteidigung Amerika gibt
tonnenweise Geld für Waffen und Soldaten
aus nicht wahr nun nein die Wahrheit ist
dass dies bei weitem nicht der
hauptausgabenposten ist tatsächlich sind
die Militärausgaben in
inflationsbereinigten Dollar sogar nicht
so stark gestiegen seit fast 20 Jahren
stagnieren sie praktisch hier könnt ihr
es
[Musik]
sehen okay aber warum steigen dann ankel
Sams Staatsausgaben Jahr für Jahr so
stark an wohin fließt das ganze Geld nun
es scheint dass sich die Situation in
diesem Fall nicht sehr von der in Europa
unterscheidet der überwiegende Teil der
haushalinflation lässt sich auf eine
Sache zurückführen Sozialausgaben okay
aber Tatsache ist auch dass die Ausgaben
des Staates im Verhältnis zum BP trotz
dieser Entwicklung jahrelang mehr oder
weniger stabil geblieben sind mit
anderen Worten die Wirtschaft wuchs der
Staat nahm mehr ein und dann leitete er
den größten Teil all dieser Mittel in
die Sozialausgaben aber er tat mehr als
das denn gleichzeitig hat der
investitionenen anderen Bereichen
reduziert ihr habt sicher schon mal
davon gehört wie schlecht die
Infrastruktur in den USA ist oder falls
nicht wir haben darüber sogar mal ein
eigenes Video gedreht und ich werde es
euch verlinken die vernachlässigte und
verrottende us-infrastruktur ist aber
nur ein Beispiel das Hauptproblem ist
dass mittlerweile das ganze System aus
den Fugen geraten ist so sind den nun
auch die öffentlichen Ausgaben im
Verhältnis zum BEP in die Höhe
geschnellt seit Beginn des 21
jahrhunderts sind die Ausgaben des
Bundes von etwa 18% auf über 30% des BIP
gestiegen selbst ohne die Pandemie ist
es gut möglich dass die Staatsausgaben
heute bei über 24 oder 25% des BP liegen
würden aber das ist nicht einmal das
größte Problem das größte Problem ist
nämlich dass dieses aus Ausgabenniveau
immer durch ein riesiges Defizit
unterstützt wurde eine Haushaltslücke
die im Jahr 2023 über 5% des BIP
betragen wird und die die
Staatsverschuldung wie eine Rakete in
die Höhe schießen lässt denkt ihr wir
würden übertreiben dann seht euch mal
das hier
an aber das ist erst der Anfang hier
sind die Daten und Prognosen des
congressional Budget Office wie ihr
sehen könnt wird das Gewicht der
bundesverschuldung im Verhältnis zum BP
von heute rund 100% auf was 200% in den
nächsten 30 Jahren ansteigen und das
obwohl sich die Staatseinnahmen
praktisch auf Rekordniveau befinden denn
bisher hatte die US-Regierung einen
enormen Vorteil da der Dollar die
internationale Leitwährung ist ist die
Nachfrage nach US-Staatsanleihen enorm
das hat es der Regierung ermöglicht ihre
Schulden so stark zu erhöhen ohne dass
die Zinssätze in die Höhe schossen na ja
und das hat dann zu Situationen wie
dieser geführt 1 August 2011 Putin
beschuldigt die USA wie ein Parasit auf
Kosten der Weltwirtschaft zu leben das
hat natürlich nichts mit der Realität zu
tun allerdings stellt sich schon die
Frage wie weit eine solche Blase noch
anschwellen kann bis sie platzt denn ist
ein solcher Weg wirklich nachhaltig oder
kommt bald das dicke Ende genau das
nehmen wir jetzt unter die
Lupe das schlimmste aller Omen ist ein
Ausfall
möglich das große schwarze Loch das die
öffentlichen Finanzen der US
Bundesregierung und übrigens auch viele
anderer Länder der Welt zerstört hat
einen Namen Sozialausgaben die
fortschreitende Überalterung der
Bevölkerung stellt eine große
Herausforderung dar bislang konnten die
USA dieses Problem vor sich herschieben
aber werden Sie in der Lage sein das
noch lange zu
tun nun im amerikanischen
Sozialversicherungssystem decken die
laufenden Einnahmen z.B nicht die von
der Regierung zugesagten Renten dennoch
schließt das System Jahr für Jahr mit
positiven Zahlen ab vor allem dank des
retirement and Survivor Fund und des
disability Fund dabei handelt es sich um
zwei Fonds die 1939 B 1956 eingerichtet
wurden um Geld für künftige
sozialversicherungszahlungen anzusparen
denn ja in den USA wird im Gegensatz zu
anderen Ländern für den Ruhestand
gespart es wird nicht nur einfach alles
sofort von einer Generation zur nächsten
umverteilt das Ergebnis bis Ende 2022
hatten diese beiden Fonds zusammen ein
Vermögen von 2,9 Billionen Dollar
gebildet aber haltet euren Jubel bitte
noch etwas zurück das Problem ist
nämlich dass auch diese Mittel in ein
paar Jahren erschöpft sein werden denn
selbst im besten Fall würden sie kaum 15
bis 16 Jahre reichen im schlimmsten Fall
gar könnten Sie in weniger als einem
Jahrzehnt erschöpft sein nach den
jüngsten Prognosen sind dabei drei
Szenarien denkbar das heißt dass der
amerikanische Staat in etwa 10 Jahren
noch mehr Schulden wird aufnehmen müssen
um die dann explodierende Rentenlücke zu
schließen
und bedenk bitte dass dies nur die erste
große Herausforderung ist die das Weiße
Haus von nun an ernst nehmen muss ganz
genau es ist die erste aber nicht die
einzige denn in der Zwischenzeit zwingen
die enormen Schulden die ang Sam bereits
gemacht hat ihn natürlich dazu Zinsen zu
zahlen und zwar ordentlich Zinsen im
Jahr 2022 z.B musste die Regierung
bereits 400 Milliarden Dollar allein für
Zinszahlungen ausgeben und natürlich
dutet angesichts der steigenden Zinsen
alles darauf hin dass dieser trag noch
weiter ansteigen wird und es werden
nicht nur der Schuldendienst und die
Sozialausgaben sein die immer weiter
steigen denn zu allem Überfluss
veranlassen die wachsende Rivalität mit
China und die Erfahrungen mit Russland
die Politiker in Washington dazu die
Militärausgaben zu erhöhen mit anderen
Worten das Finanzministerium wird mit
einer Menge neuer Ausgaben jonglieren
müssen die alle auf einmal kommen wohl
gemerkt auch ein Regierungswechsel wird
wohl kaum etwas daran ändern in den
letzten Jahrzehnten waren sich alle
Parteien am Ende jedes Obergrenzen
shutdown the das einig dass es in
Ordnung ist immer mehr auszugeben im
Jahr 2023 haben wir erlebt wie die
fehlende Einigung über die Verlängerung
der Schulden Obergrenze beinahe zu einem
Zahlungsausfall geführt hätte und wieder
wurde das Problem nicht gelöst sondern
im Grunde nur hinausgezögert und
deswegen kann ich euch versichern dass
dies ein Thema sein wird das immer mehr
ins Rampenlicht rückt der Status des
Dollars als sicherer Hafen macht es fast
undenkbar dass die Vereinigten Staaten
ihre Zahlungen einstellen könnten es sei
denn es käme eines Tages dann doch zu
einer pol
Meinungsverschiedenheit die nicht mehr
aufgelöst werden
kann und dann würde sich die
amerikanische schuldenkatze in ihren
eigenen Schwanz beißen denn die Dominanz
des Dollars beruht auf dem Vertrauen in
die US-Wirtschaft und auch auf der
Gesundheit der öffentlichen Finanzen
ersterem geht es im allgemeinen gut
letzterem geht es eher schlecht als
recht die durch den permanenten
schatdown Stress verursachte
Unsicherheit bringt jedoch auch den
ersten Pfeiler immer mehr ins Wanken es
wird also nicht heute passieren und
vielleicht auch nicht morgen aber früher
oder später und lieber früher als später
wird Washington eine Lösung finden
müssen jahrzehnelang konnten sie mit
einem chronischen Haushaltsloch leben
aber es wird immer größer und bald
unhaltbar klar der US-Wirtschaft geht es
noch einigermaßen gut sie macht ihren
Job aber die Politiker in Washington
machen ihn nicht und das bedeutet dass
viele Analysten mittelfristig nicht
ausschließen dass die Spannungen immer
weiter zunehmen werden bis die Lage
kritisch wird und kippt vor allem wenn
man B den dass in ein paar Jahren auch
die Renten mit Schulden finanziert
werden müssen noch haben die Amis Zeit
aber diese fiskalische Bombe ist
zweifellos eine weitere der großen
Bedrohungen sowohl für die Vereinigten
Staaten als auch für die Weltwirtschaft
ein Zahlungsausfall wäre beispiellos und
könnte katastrophale Folgen haben die
Kreditmärkte könnten Einfrieren der Wert
des Dollars könnte abstürzen die
US-Zinsen könnten in die Höhe schießen
die negativen Auswirkungen könnten auf
die ganze Welt ausstrahlen und es könnte
zu einer Finanzkrise und Rezession
kommen die an die Ereignisse von 2008
oder noch schlimmer erinnern könnte
klingt nicht besonders gut nicht wahr
und trotzdem ist dies nur eine der
Bedrohungen denen die USA in Zukunft
ausgesetzt sind über die anderen haben
wir noch so einige Videos zu drehen
vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo
unbedingt mitglöckchen falls sie euch
auch interessieren und bis dahin würde
mich erstmal wieder eure Meinung
interessieren glaubt ihr dass Washington
dieses Problem überhaupt irgendwann
ernst nehmen wird was würdet ihr tun um
es zu lösen werden sich die Dinge von
selbst regeln und wie wird diese ganze
Geschichte wohl enden schreibt uns eure
Einschätzung bitte in den
Kommentarbereich unter diesem Video und
vergesst bitte auch nicht auf meinen
neuen Kanal vorbeizuschauen den ich euch
ebenfalls in der Videobeschreibung und
hinter dem i oben rechts verlinke ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein
Like tes mit euren Freunden und
diskutiert es mit ihnen natürlich freuen
wir uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch mit uns dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung und dem Video
macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald